ausgerechnet in der ersten sendung nach
ostern feiern wir gemeinsam die
wiederauferstehung des öffentlichen
lebens wo sie an der lock down wird
gelockert
also leicht gelockert leicht das krone
virus bleibt natürlich erstmal teil
unseres alltagslebens ja müssen uns
daran gewöhnen der bleibt kennen sie
bestimmt von zu hause wenn einer
einfachen nicht ausziehen wird aber
immerhin am mittwoch am vergangenen
mittwoch gab es frohe kunde jauchzen und
frohlocken auf allen kanälen es ist der
große tag der entscheidung wie geht es
weiter mit der korona krise der
augenblick der wahrheit rückt näher
liegt jetzt bei uns weiter heute ist der
tag der tage der tag der entscheidung
die spannung steigt das muss man schon
wirklich sagen sind sie auch schon so
gespannt welche lockerungen der chor
ohne regeln es geben wird
das ist so spannende sache war das
auflegen oder beziehungsweise mittel
aufregend denn die kontakt
beschränkungen bleiben ja zurecht damit
muss nicht gleich wieder alles kaputt
machen
friseure zb sind noch mindestens zwei
wochen zu mindestens zwei wochen
wie sagen wenn mein pony so weiter
wechseln kann ich mein telefon dabei gar
nicht mehr lesen aber genug von mir
geschäftemachen kommenden montag wieder
auf aber nur bis maximal 800
quadratmeter warum gerade 800 das weiß
keiner und es gibt ausnahmen bei manchen
geschäften spielt die größe keine rolle
das gilt für autohäuser fahrradläden und
für buchhandlungen macht sinn wenn die
autohäuser endlich wieder voller werden
wenn vielleicht die frauenhäuser wieder
lehrer warum ausnahme für große
autohäuser aber nicht für möbelhäuser
fun fact am rande die neue präsidentin
des bundesverbands der
automobilindustrie oberster autolobby
ist denn hildegard müller war mal drei
jahre staatsministerin angela merkels
kanzleramt aber ich sehe da keinen
zusammenhang
und ansonsten gelten natürlich weiter
ganz wichtig alle hygiene und
abstandsregeln die gelten weiter man
empfiehlt uns dringend masken zu tragen
im öffentlichen raum aber es gibt keine
pflicht denn dann würde auch der letzte
merken dass wir von den guten masken
immer noch viel zu wenig haben außerdem
ist
auch gar nicht so einfach die teile
richtig zu bedienen das waren die maske
des verhärtungen es bleibt nicht
trainieren
das war doppelt falsch ist mir auch
schon passiert ist uns allen schon
passiert übrigens direkt danach ist er
noch mit kollege bouffier und circa 30
ärztin ein aufzug gestiegen
einfach nur um kindern mal zu zeigen wie
man es absolut nicht machen soll
ansonsten macht der spanier einen
anständigen krisen job und zu weit
gehört auch dass mit den masken ist
wirklich schwieriger als man denkt
wirklich schwieriger das sagen ihnen
sogar experten eben dadurch dass wir
darauf achten dass er mit dem gesicht
mit den händen nicht in die hand fassen
ins gesicht fassen müssen unbedingt
darauf achten dass man sich so verhält
als wäre schon die ihre voller masten
die maske kollabieren
das heißt jeder masken sind ja nicht für
den eigenschutz gedacht unbedingt
sondern dafür andere anzustecken
so habe ich auch verstanden außerdem gab
es mittwoch noch ganz wichtige
entscheidungen zum thema schule ab dem
vierten mai soll es wieder losgehen
zunächst nur für abschlussklassen aber
selbstverständlich wird das dann kein
normaler schulalltag wie denn auch in
zeiten von corona die schüler müssen die
üblichen abstände einhalten wofür aber
viele klassenzimmer selbst bei kleineren
lerngruppen gar nicht gebaut sind von
den exotischen wünschen mancher
pädagogen zum schulstart mal ganz zu
schweigen wenn sie anfängt und da hoffen
wir wirklich dass das möglichst schnell
ist müssen aber auch
mindestvoraussetzungen erfüllt werden
insbesondere im hygienischen bereich
benötigen wir danach in den schulen
waschbecken die funktionieren warmes
wasser seife seife die feine dame die da
viele städten im ruhrgebiet kriegen
demnächst zum ersten mal seife und ich
wünschte das wäre ein witz sein
das wird ein hallo geben so hefte raus
textaufgabe was wir wissen ist dass
durchschnittlich über ein drittel der
lehrkräfte über 50 ist dass wir einen
sehr großen lehrkräften mangeln haben
und wenn wir dann die risikogruppen
sind ja aus der schule draußen wer macht
denn dann den unterricht der hausmeister
der eklige typ im trenchcoat der immer
vor der schule herumlungert und fotos
macht ich habe keine ahnung
keine ahnung in vielen bundesländern hat
man erst vor kurzem lehrer aus der rente
zurückgeholt die können jetzt alle nicht
mehr unterrichten risikogruppe klar
risikogruppe wie sollen die schulen mit
weniger lehrern mehr unterrichten
ja genau dazu sollen sich die
schulbehörden in den nächsten zwei
wochen
zitat konzepte überlegen toi toi toi man
müsste endlich mal ehrlich sein zu den
menschen normal war gestern
und nein wir werden auch in den
sommerferien nicht in den urlaub fahren
und hier ist doch auch schön so luckner
roth tv mit ralf kabelka ein traum wird
wahr liebe zuschauer ferne länder neue
eindrücke echte abenteuer all das fällt
dieses jahr komplett aus rufen sie jetzt
an und buchen sie unser exklusives paket
sechs wochen am stück bei affenhitze zu
hause statt sich am pool um die letzte
liege zu prügeln genießen sie das worum
uns die ganze welt beneidet die magische
zweisamkeit der legendären deutschen ehe
wie schön wenn man auch nach 20 jahren
noch gemeinsam lachen kann inklusive
halbpension die ihre frau selber kocht
klassiker wie fischstäbchen mit
remoulade miracoli und natürlich muttis
rest pfanne aus fischstäbchen und
miracoli mit remoulade wer braucht
ausflüge in vergammelte antike tempel
die wahren highlight lauern direkt um
die ecke
der recyclinghof willkommene abwechslung
in zeiten der korona quarantäne
wertstoffhof tourismus nennen das die
müllwerker
und der osterferien situation hat auch
mit der ganzen familie h wir fahren zum
wertstoffhof jubeln wie teenager
wir wollen alte batterien aus dem keller
holen und wie wäre es danach mit einem
abendlichen bummel durch die
fußgängerzone von bielefeld der stadt
die immer schläft haben alle läden zu
wiegen corona oder einfach nur wegen
bielefeld man weiß es nicht endlich zur
ruhe kommen mit entschleunigung und
achtsamkeit warum nicht mal ein zwei
stunden gucken was man so alles zwischen
den zehen findet marianne freitags
diesen sommer rechnet sich endlich auch
ihr sky abo es läuft zwar kein aktueller
fußball mehr aber dafür alte spiele aus
den 90ern daran hat die ganze familie
spaß
buchen sie jetzt unser paket den ganzen
sommer bei affen
sonnenklar.tv
[Musik]
was ich über meinen arsch geigensolo war
doch versprochen ihr könnt ihr in der
zeit den kanal abonnieren
[Musik]